[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
l'anatomie comparée pour les nuls avec
des aliens alors suite à ma la dernière
vidéo j'ai reçu énormément de
commentaires de gens cherchant à me
convaincre que il existait des momies
d'alien ou des cadavres d'alien qui
avait été découvert et qui était très
convaincant tout cas bien plus
convaincant que le cas que j'ai commenté
dans ma dernière vidéo que je vous
invite à voir si vous ne l'avez pas déjà
vu qu'il s'agissait d'une momie dans
fait d'un de ce que j'interprète comme
étant tout simplement un être humain
mais qui a été mutilé selon moi et
est-ce qui est ce qui m'a beaucoup peiné
revêt au moment où j'ai fait la vidéo
puisque pour moi il s'agissait très
probablement d'une véritable momie
humaine donc d'un objet archéologique
extrêmement précieux ou d'un cadavre
humain qui avaient été pillés dans une
tombe qui donc avait été mutilée pour
faire cette pseudo aliens donc pour moi
c'était un acte qui était vraiment assez
répréhensibles qui se devait d'être
dénoncé donc pour le coup je vais
essayer de faire cette nouvelle vidéo
ici plus calme plus plu sera et on va
essayer de la mettre sous le signe de l'
intégrité intellectuelle de l'honnêteté
intellectuelle
donc qu'est ce que j'appelle haute et
honnêteté intellectuelle et bien je vais
passer en revue différents cas
d'extraterrestres de soi disant
extraterrestres qui m'ont été envoyés
donc dans les commentaires de la vidéo
précédente donc c'est à dire que les
gens m'ont envoyé des réponses ils m'ont
dit ah oui mais si ce qu'allah te
convainc pas tiens on regarde ce cas ci
il est beaucoup plus convaincant voilà
on en a envoyé des dizaines comme ça et
je vais vous montrer ses différents
extraterrestre enfin ces différents
possibles extra terrestres et sous la
lumière de l'anatomie comparée bien on
va essayer de voir si honnêtement on
peut en conclure qu'il s'agit d'extra
terrestres ou bien s'il ne peut pas
s'agir de quelque chose qui existe déjà
sur terre si on arrive à aller comparer
à quelque chose qui existe sur terre
c'est que fatalement ça a quand même
plus de chances de venir de la terre que
d'ailleurs si ça ressemble pas un être
humain c'est forcément un extraterrestre
non c'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
l'anatomie comparée l'anatomie comparée
sait si ça ressemble pas un humain tu
vas essayer de comparer ça à d'autres
animaux qui vivent sur terre et une fois
que tu auras comparer ça à suffisamment
d'animaux qui vivent sur terre pour en
conclure qu'il ne s'agit d'aucun cela
l'a éventuellement tu pourras camp
c'est à y mettre l'hypothèse qu'il
s'agit d'un extraterrestre c'est comme
ça que ça marche l'anatomie comparée
l'anatomie comparée on se contente pas
juste de dire c'est pas humain donc ces
extraterrestres donc je vais
majoritairement me baser sur des
radiographies
pourquoi les radiographies d'une part
parce que je suis plutôt spécialiste du
squelette
donc à partir du moment où il ya de la
viande ça m'intéresse pas trop les
radiographies ça permet d'enlever la
viande et je vais m'intéresser aux
radiographies aussi parce que on m'a
reproché qu' il fallait que je regarde
le matériel original et pas seulement
les photos
ben en l'occurrence les radiographies de
toute façon les gens n'ont rien d'autre
ce sont des photos des photos qui
passent au travers du spécimen on est
d'accord qui passent au travers du
squelette mais ça reste des photos donc
les gens qui étudient ces spécimens basé
sur les radiographies n'ont rien de
mieux que les radiographies non plus
voilà au moins on est sur un pied
d'égalité de ce point de vue là alors
soyons bien d'accord je vais mettre
quelque chose au point tout de suite je
ne suis pas contre l'existence d'une vie
extraterrestre j'ai même fait une vidéo
consacrée à la possibilité d'une et de
l'existence d'une vie sur mars dans
laquelle ma conclusion était que la vie
avait au moins existait à un moment sur
mars
et ben on va peut-être que du coup elle
existe encore planqué dans un coin mais
là où je conteste c'est que cette vie
pourrait ressembler à l'homme ou même à
quoi que ce soit qui existe sur terre
parce que si quelque chose ressemble à
ceux qui vit sur terre ça quand même
beaucoup plus de chances d'être terriens
qu'autre chose la vie sur terre est
basée sur de l'adn l'adn est une
molécule extrêmement complexe dont
l'évolution a été extrêmement
contingentes est extrêmement influencé
par le hasard
il n'est même pas dit que si on
rembobine est la vie sur terre et qu'on
la reprenait au début elle aboutirait au
même résultat et en l'occurrence à
l'apparition de l'être humain
l'être humain ne réapparaîtrait
peut-être pas si on recommençait la vie
sur terre dans les mêmes conditions
exactement les mêmes conditions
maintenant imaginez qu'on démarre d'un
poids ou la gravité les climats les
continents ne sont pas les mêmes sur une
autre planète
à votre avis quelle est la probabilité
pour qu'un être humain apparaissent à
l'issue de sa et quelle est la
probabilité pour qu'une molécule qui
ressemble même un tant soit peu à l'adn
apparaissent à l'issue de sa non non non
si la vie à un point de départ
différents ya zéro probabilité pour que
des milliards d'années d'évolution plus
tard elles aboutissent à un endroit qui
soit un tant soit peu proche de ce qui
ressemble sur terre
donc voilà ça c'est ce que je
est si ça ressemble de l'être humain si
ça ressemble même à quoi que ce soit qui
existe sur terre si ça une tête deux
bras deux jambes
la première hypothèse qui voit qui doit
vous venir à l'esprit c'est pas
l'hypothèse extraterrestre
c'est l'hypothèse c'est peut-être un
truc qui vit sur terre mais qui est très
moche et c'est généralement le cas mais
ça on va le voir durant la vidéo et
c'est pour ça que l'anatomie comparée va
être importante et c'est pour ça que
j'ai appelé cette vidéo l'anatomie
comparée pour les nuls et à l'occasion
moi ça me permet de vous faire un petit
cours d'anatomie comparée ce que j'aime
beaucoup faire ces avec des cas un peu
marrant un petit peu qu'ils sortent du
commun va plutôt que de vous montrer des
squelettes de trucs voilà comme ça qui
sont inintéressants balles à jose montre
des squelettes qui sont très
intéressants puisque les gens pensent
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'être humain mais
d'être qui viennent d'une autre planète
sans plus de discussions commencées
alors déjà je vais revenir rapidement
sur le l'extraterrestre que j'ai fait
que j'ai traité dans la vidéo précédente
parce que je n'ai pas parlé de sa tête
et voici le crâne de cet extraterrestre
alors juste pour faire un petit point
épistémologique je me fous de qui a fait
cette découverte d'ailleurs à travers
toute la vidéo que vous allez voir
maintenant je me fous des gens qui ont
fait la découverte je me fous de qui les
a rendues publiques je me fous
complètement
de qui à qui la faute traitement et je
me fiche aussi de leur motivation je
sais pas s'ils ont fait ça pour la
gloire pour la science pour le pognon je
m'en fous moi tout ce que je constate
c'est le spécimen
je me fiche de l'autorité des gens qui
ont fait ça si ils sont très sérieux
dommages pour enfin s'ils sont très
sérieux et qu'ils ont fait une
découverte qui n'est pas une réelle
découverte c'est tant pis pour eux et
s'ils sont pas sérieux et qu'ils ont
fait une découverte qui est très
importante et ben c'est tant mieux pour
eux voilà donc ce spécimen alors je
n'avais pas parlé du crâne
dans la dernière vidéo parce que tout
simplement c'est le c'est l'exemple
classique voilà d'un crâne qui ressemble
pas un crâne humain parce que il à la
boîte crânienne un petit peu oblongue un
petit peu ovale en vue latérale comme on
peut le voir sur cette radiographie
mais bon c'est quand même pas un truc
qui se rencontrent jamais sur terre que
le nigeria il ya des gens sur terre qui
ont des crânes de forme oblongue parce
que culturellement il attache en fait
c'est un geste culturel il attache une
genre de bande autour du crâne des bébés
quand crâne n'est pas encore aussi fier
et puis bah du coup pendant la
croissance le crâne va prendre une forme
qui va être plus blonde que normal il ya
des gens qui trouvent ça très beau
trouver à crâne qui ressemble à un crâne
humain mais qui est de forme oblongue ça
fait pas de ce crâne d'un crâne
extraterrestres en tout cas si on a un
minimum donnés de théâtre
actuelle on ne peut pas conclure à un
crâne extraterrestre juste en regardant
ce caractère là mais en l'occurrence
cette momie elle a d'autres
caractéristiques qui sont bizarres et
notamment le nombre de doigts et il ne
s'agit pas de la seule et ça aussi c'est
un argument important en la faveur de
l'existence de ces extraterrestres
c'est que on a trouvé beaucoup de
spécimens donc là je vous en mets mais
je vous ai mis à gauche
le spécimen dont je parlais dans la
dernière vidéo et je vous ai mis à
droite un des nombreux exemples de
spécimens qui ont été retrouvés et qui
ont trois doigts 3 3 doit très très long
et donc ça effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui n'existe pas vraiment sur
terre bon à part chez le paresseux le
paresseux à trois doigts à trois très
longs doigts mais là en l'occurrence on
n'est pas du tout face à une anatomie
qui ressemble ni de près ni de loin à
celle des mains du paresseux à trois
doigts
donc là je suis d'accord il ya une
bizarrerie là quelque chose il ya
quelque chose qui ne s'expliquent pas
facilement alors voici le laus théologie
d'une main humaine vous avez les
phalanges dont qui forment les doigts la
partie mobile de la main et vous avez ce
qu'on appelle les mets ta carte qui sont
les très longs ce que vous voyez en bas
de la main et qui forment la paume de la
main donc la partie un petit peu moins
mobiles et après vous avez
l'articulation du poignet indiqué par
cette grosse flèche les métacarpe ce
sont les eaux sur l'image ils sont
reliés vers le bas au poignet et vers le
haut aux phalanges et ce sont deux des
eaux qui sont caractéristiques mans plus
long que les phalanges
donc ça c'est une masse humaine et voici
maintenant la main extraterrestre donc
on reconnaît les trois doigts très très
long mais surtout ce qu'on reconnaît
bien c'est une anatomie qui nous est
très familière à savoir des phalanges
des mets ta carte et un poignet en bas
et je suis un infâme menteur parce qu'il
ne s'agit pas du tout d'une main
extraterrestres en réalité il s'agit
d'une humaine sur laquelle on a juste
des coupes et deux doigts le petit doigt
et le pouce et surtout on a découpé la
peau entre les métacarpe afin que les
métacarpe ressemblent à des phalanges
afin de donner l'impression que les
doigts sont plus longs mais on reconnaît
toujours que ce sont des métacarpe
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont articulées au
poignet et qu'ils sont articulés à des
phalanges plus petit vers le haut alors
maintenant regarder ces extraterrestres
qu'est ce qu'on constate à gauche ce
sont des pieds donc on parle pas de mes
ta carte mais de métatarse mais on
constate la même chose on a des
phalanges
on a des longs zoo à la base qui
qui sont les métatarse et qui sont
eux-mêmes articulé non pas aux os du
poignet indiqué par cette grosse flèche
mais aux os de la cheville et sur celle
de droite et bien qu est-ce qu on
constate des petite phalange de long
mais ta carte est pareil les os du
poignet donc en réalité ce qu'on a face
à nous ça a quand même plus de chances
d'être des mains et des pieds humains
qui ont été mutilés dont on a enlevé les
pousser les les petits doigts plutôt que
d authentiques ma extraterrestre alors
celle de gauche c'est certainement un
humain celle de droite je n'y a pas
d'échelle donc je ne sais pas quelle
taille fait ce spécimen mais les doigts
ressemble pas enfin les phalanges
ressemblent pas à des phalanges humaine
griffe à la fin donc c'est peut-être
même chaque bon voilà ils ont
certainement mutilés et un cadavres de
chat pour faire ça mais quoi qu'il en
soit il n'y a rien qu'on ne puisse pas
expliqué avec des choses qui sont sur
terre donc honnêtement je ne peux pas
conclure que ces choses face à moi sont
des extraterrestres
donc si on fait preuve d'honnêteté
intellectuelle eh ben je suis désolé
mais tout ça c'est bullshit
voilà en fait le cas suivant c'est la
créature de mette à pecq donc encore une
sorte de momies bizarroïde qui a été
découverte en amérique du sud
de toute façon la plupart des choses que
je vais vous montrer vienne ou
d'amérique du sud ou de sibérie puisque
ce sont des milieux de momification
extrêmement extrêmement facile en
sibérie on obtient facilement des momies
parce que les cadavres gel naturellement
dans la glace le processus de
momification n'applique pas forcément
une activité humaine
il ya des modifications qui sont
complètement naturel donc la glace est
un facteur de modifications mais la
sécheresse et notamment le désert
d'atacama qui sait qu'au monde
la sécheresse a dû aussi la momification
c'est à dire que en gros le corps sèche
tellement vite qu'il n'a même pas le
temps de courir en sibérie c'est le
froid qui empêche de pourrir et en
amérique du sud c'est plutôt la
sécheresse qui empêche donc ya pas
forcément d'activités humaines dans un
processus de modification
la modification ça peut être aussi
naturel donc là on aurait une momie plus
ou moins naturel d'un être qui lie à un
crâne quand même vachement bizarre avec
de gros
aux yeux avec au cerveau avec des danses
[ __ ] les jetons donc on est on est en
droit légitimement de se dire que quand
même ce truc là ça pas l'être humain a
l'air franchement de quelque chose d'un
monstre qu'on ne connaît pas chez nous
et puis ensuite on peut regarder les
dents on voit qu'il ya une canine là au
milieu de la mâchoire et puis il y a des
incisives à l'avant et des molaires à
l'arrière et ça c'est quand même plutôt
caractéristiques des mammifères dire sur
terre il ya que les mammifères qui ont
une canine des incisives à l'avant et
des molaires à l'arrière molaires et
prémolaires à l'arrière donc là à priori
moi quand je vois ça on me montre ça je
me dis bon ok c'est moche ça a pris cher
dans sa phase mais ça encore une
dentition de mammifères dont il est
possible que ce soit un mammifère aussi
ok parmi les mammifères je regarde les
incisives deux incisives par denis
mâchoire donc ici indiqué par les
flèches quelle catégorie de mammifères à
deux incisives par denis mâchoire ce
sont les primates et uniquement les
primates
donc on serait fasse éventuellement à un
petit singe d'après cette image
et quand on connaît les mammifères et
bien on sait que parmi les mammifères
ceux qui ont le cerveau le plus gros la
boîte crânienne la plus volumineuse et
bien ce sont les primates tous les
primates ont un cerveau qui est
globalement plus gros que celui des
autres mammifères dont ça collerait
plutôt bien avec la taille de cette
boîte crânienne et en l'occurrence quel
est le primate
quels sont les primates les plus
nombreux en amérique du sud et bien ce
sont les marmousets voici le crâne d'un
art musique il apparaît à la droite
vous voyez les deux incisives indiqué
par les flèches canine les molaires
derrière et vous voyez la taille de la
boîte crânienne dont vous voyez la boîte
crânienne de forme oblongue qui
correspond très bien à celle de la
créature de meta peck et les yeux les
yeux sont très très gros et vous voyez
que sur la créature de mme étape est que
les yeux aussi son sont très très gros
et alors il ya des petites différences
quand même il ya pas mal de petites
différences là en particulier où la
créature de meta pec diffère un peu du
marmousez c'est le nombre de dents après
la canine donc vous pouvez voir que sur
la photo de droite qu'il y à beaucoup
plus de prémolaires et de molaire chez
le mar musée qu'il y en a chez la
créature de meta peixe la créature de
meta paix qui en a que 3 et du coup ça
ça ça s'explique relativement simplement
par le fait qu' il pourrait les
créatures de meta pec pourrait être une
sorte de petit primate sud-américain
juvénile
elle garantit pas que ce soit à ma
musique mais il pourrait s'agir d'un
petit primate
veine il est du coup à toutes ces
demandes ne seraient pas sorte et on
sait que les juvéniles ont globalement
une boîte crânienne et des yeux qui sont
globalement plus gros
proportionnellement reste du crâne que
chez les adultes
donc ce qui augmenterait un peu cet
effet aliens c'est à dire c'est la
taille de ses orbites et la taille du
crâne par rapport au reste du corps tout
semble pointer vers la direction d'une
espèce de momies très mal préservé de
marc musée d'un autre primate
sud-américains dont les oreilles aurait
été abîmée enfin bref la partie charnue
aurait salma prix mais la partie osseuse
en tout cas correspond assez bien à la
description qu'on pourrait faire d'un
jeune d'un jeune primates sud américain
et quand on regarde le corps tout entier
de ce monstre de cette créature de
mettre à pecq d'akio voit-on on voit un
pouce opposable flèche du haut et on
voit une queue musculeuse flèche du bas
deux caractéristiques que l'on retrouve
chez les primates sud-américain savoir
le plus opposable qui est une
caractéristique de tous les primates et
là que musculeuse qui permet de se
suspendre aux branches et qui est aussi
caractéristique de nombreux primates sud
américain donc a priori il ya aucune
raison de penser que le la créature de
meta peck est autre chose qu'un petit
singe et pour les plus sceptiques qui
penserait que ceci n'est pas un petit
sage et que non en fait je dis des
conneries et puis j'ai pas de preuve et
rallier tralala sachez que la créature
de met apec a fait l'objet d'une analyse
adn et que cette analyse adn a
formellement identifié cet animal comme
étant justement un marmousez donc voilà
la puissance de l'anatomie comparée
quand on se contente pas de dire que a
c'est juste différent de ce que je
connais et qu'on commence un petit peu à
regarder notamment l'anatomie dentaire
et bien on constate qu'il ya une
explication qui est beaucoup plus simple
que celle d'une explication
extraterrestre
après voici deux nouveaux spécimens et
là j'ai été un peu plus embêté j'ai été
un peu plus embêté avec ses deux
spécimens là parce que là on est face à
deux crânes avec un peu d'eux est un peu
de viande dessus mais on sait pas trop
si c'est de la viande c'est un peu de la
viande séchée coincée de la momification
apparemment mais ces petits crânes
qu'ils ont un très gros cerveau ils ont
de très gros yeux donc on pourrait dire
ah ouais ça aussi c'est du marmousez
mais le problème c'est qu'ils ont cette
petite crête sur le dessus de la tête
et cette petite
crête sur le dessus de la tête qui
s'appelle la crête sagittale n'est pas
présente chez les primates direction les
radiographies
or voici la radiographie de l'un de ces
crânes déjà sur cette radio ce qui m'a
choqué en premier c'est l'absence totale
de dents vous voyez la face et sur le
côté droit là et j'ai encerclé la partie
on devrait trouver les dents et on voit
rien on voit rien du tout et les dents
c'est quand même le truc qui ressort le
plus d'habitude sur les radiographies et
en fait ce qui choque aussi c'est que ya
pas de dents mais il n'y a pas d'eau ce
non plus autour de la bouche c'est à
dire qu'on a une bouche qui est
complètement entouré par du tissu mou ya
aucun n'ose à l'intérieur de la bouche
alors que normalement on devrait voir
les os du nez on devrait voir les eaux
des mâchoires devrait voir la mandibule
bref il ya un truc bizarre il se passe
rien là au niveau de cette mâchoire et
ça c'est pas normal
et du coup je me suis dit ben je vais
comparer sa crainte de chat en
radiographie et quand on compare à un
crâne de chat donc déjà vous pouvez
constater que les dents ressortent très
bien sur le crâne de chat mais du coup
si on veut obtenir un résultat qui est
similaire à ce qu'on a sur la gauche eh
bien il faut retirer la phase du chat
parce que sur notre spécimen ya pas d'os
dans la face alors retirons la face du
chat voilà on retire la partie qui
correspond au visage et là qu'est ce
qu'on constate et bien on constate que
le chat et le petit crâne dont on ne
savait pas expliquer l'origine
contiennent un cerveau un cervelet et
une bulletin panique qu'on arrive à voir
en transparence on peut reconnaître les
structures à l'intérieur cerveau
cervelet et bulletins panique et surtout
ce qu'on arrive à reconnaître c'est une
petite crête osseuse qu'on loi sur la
radiographie qui s'appelle le temps
torrione le temps thorium c'est une
sorte de crête qui sépare le cerveau du
cervelet dans le crâne des carnivores
des chats des chiens aussi et qui est
réellement mais complètement typique des
mammifères carnivores
on la retrouve quasiment jamais chez
aucun autre groupe de manifeste
d'animaux en général et là en
l'occurrence et bien si vous regardez
sur la gauche les petits crânes avec une
crête sagittale les p'tits cracks
curieux qu'on a vu tout à l'heure et
bien ils ont une crête tantôt rienne
donc ils ont un temps thorium qui sépare
leur cervelet et leur cerveau donc a
priori on a de bonnes raisons de croire
qu'il pourrait s'agir d'achats et en
l'occurrence les chats ont une crête
sagittale donc c'est bullshit
à gauche est en fait une fois de plus
ses petits crânes
ils ont tout l'air d'être des crânes de
chat donc l on a cassé l'avant de la
face et on a sculpté à la place du
visage de chat et bien on a sculpté en
jeu c'est pas une sorte de pâte j'en
sais rien en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya pas dos en dessous donc
on a sculpté des mâchoires et un visage
en a sculpté à visage par dessus un
crâne de chats qu'on a cassé donc cas
suivants cas suivants et qui m'a donné
du fil à retordre aux si c'est ça alors
c'est quelque chose qui est très curieux
parce qu'en fait ça a été identifié
comme une fesse a aussi été identifié
comme un démon alors si c'est une fée
momifié j'imagine qu'une fée momifié
peut ressembler aussi un petit démon
c'est vraiment un tout petit tout écart
vous voyez la taille des mâts par
rapport à la taille du spécimen
on s'est vraiment quelque chose de très
curieux ça a des petites oreilles
pointues
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui à l'air
extrêmement bizarre
et là où c'est encore plus bizarre c'est
qu'il ya des analyses adn qui ont été
faites dessus et que ces analyses adn
montré contrairement à notre marmouzic
tout à l'heure que dans ce cas là il
s'agissait pas d'un animal mais qu'il
s'agissait d'un être humain donc les
années les analyses adn disent que l'adn
est à 98 % de l'adn humain bon que
conclure de ça certainement qu'il y a
des gros doigts tout sale qui ont
contaminé le spécimen parce que je veux
dire sans remettre en question
l'authenticité du spécimen sans s'en
remettent en question quoi que ce soit
la meilleure chance qu'on est pour
qu'une analyse adn d'un objet
archéologique comme ça ou d'une momie
donne un résultat qui est 100% humains
ou 98% il m'a alors que la chose en
question n'a pas du tout l'air humaine
c'est une contamination
donc en gros il ya des gros doigts tout
sale qui ont trop tripoter la bestiole
et puis quand ils ont pris l'échantillon
de la bestiole et ben du coup ils ont
ils ont séquencé l'adn des humains qui
ont tripoté la bestiole est pas la
bestiole elle même donc là je pense
qu'il ya eu sérieusement contamination
mais alors du coup quelle est cette
créature si l'adn n'a pas donné de
résultat si si on n'arrive pas à
extraire l'adn dessus il ya tellement
pad adn dessus qu'on arrive ne à
extraire l'adn des gens qui la tripote
que l'adn de la bestiole elle même et
bien encore une fois on fait des
radiographies ont déjà première surprise
cette chose un véritable squelette
c'est quelque chose que j'ai pas précisé
jusqu'à présent mais jusque là on est
quand même face à des à des cas
ou quand on fait la radiographie on
découvre pas qu'il s'agit juste d'un
assemblage de n'importe quoi il ya vrai
squelette en dessous on constate déjà
que les doigts donc ce qu'on a pris pour
les doigts en fait ce sont pas
réellement des doigts c'est l'extrémité
de du radius et de l'una qui a été péter
et s'éteint et qui est aussi un peu a
rassemblé avec les os du poignet pour
former à une sorte de crochet qui
ressemble de l'extérieur à des doigts
mais qui de l'intérieur n'a rien à voir
avec des doigts donc déjà premières
constatations
y'a pas de doigt sur ce squelette ce
qu'on prend pour les doigts en réalité
c'est une association des os du poignet
plus fracture de l'avant bras maintenant
penchons nous sur le crâne alors on voit
déjà que ce crâne a des dents
contrairement aux petits chats de tout à
l'heure ce crâne a des dents donc a
priori n'a pas été trop altérés et là où
je vois quelque chose qui m'évoque une
anatomie que je connais déjà et bien
c'est les grandes dans le crâne qui est
extrêmement globuleux et le prog natis
mme c'est à dire la mandibule inférieure
qui vient l'avant de la mâchoire
supérieure donc la mandibule et plus
longue que le que la mâchoire supérieure
et ça donc cette se promena tismée bien
c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve chez
les chiroptères donc chez les
chauves-souris donc à gauche vous avez
le crâne d'une chauve-souris vampire
sud-américaine et vous pouvez voir donc
le progrès nautisme sur cette
chauve-souris vampire et la grosse dent
du dessus cette grosse dent du dessus
qu'on retrouve aussi sur le spécimen de
démons slash fait slash êtres humains et
surtout on retrouve et bien la forme
globuleuses du crâne
alors après il ya des différences parce
que là j'ai pris une chauve souris
vampire et que je suis pas sûr du tout
que ce que ce crâne soit le crâne chauve
souris vampire sur la radio de droite
c'est probablement autre chose et je
suis pas sûr d'accord d'ailleurs que le
crâne n'est pas été modifiées là mais
par contre ce dont je suis sûr c'est que
les chauves souris sont caractérisés par
une chose très importante et c'est leurs
oreilles les chauves souris sont des
êtres qui pratiquent les colocations et
qui du coup ont une oreille qui est
extrêmement gros c'est extrêmement
modifié et qu'est ce qu'on voit sur
cette radiographie une oreille interne
extrêmement gross est extrêmement
modifié donc ya pas de doute on est bel
et bien face ici à un chiroptère alors
maintenant comment ce chiroptères s'est
retrouvé avec les ailes dans le dos au
lieu de les avoir au bout des mâts mais
regardez les
d'un chiroptères en radiographie oncle
lda chiroptères c'est un bras c'est un
bras normale avec une main normale au
bout
sauf que cette main est là les doigts
super long et c'est la peau tendue sur
ses doigts super nom qui va créer une l1
déjà comparons le bras du chiroptères
l'avant toit du chiroptères avec
l'avant-bras de cette bestiole de la
fait et on voit qu'ils ont la même
longueur une longueur très similaires
comparer encore et la même courbe urria
vous voyez cette petite coude et qu'il y
a un milieu qui est très typique des
chiroptères qui aide justement à cette
forme de l'aisne qui est si typique des
chiroptères donc l'avant bras à une
forme qui est très similaire à celle
d'un avant-bras de chiroptères et
surtout rappelez vous on avait dit tout
à l'heure que les en fait il n'y avait
pas de doigts que les doigts avait été
enlevé et que tout ce qu'on avait bien
c'était les os du poignet associé avec
une fracture de l'avant-bras et bien la
regarder si vous coupez les doigts de la
chauve souris et que voulait lui coller
dans le dos bah ça vous donne votre fait
voilà on peut même regarder ici regardez
l'articulation des différentes phalange
de la chauve souris
on la retrouve sur les ailes de la
petite fée look en l'occurrence comme on
le disait tout à l'heure soit ya eu
contamination de l'adn soit il ya un
être humain qui a violé une chauve
souris mais quoi qu'il arrive ceci n'est
pas une fin ceci est juste une chauve
souris qui a été très habilement
modifier très habilement vu de
l'extérieur parce que vu de l'intérieur
de toute façon ça transparaît
complètement que les ailes sont en fait
des phalanges qui ont été collées sur le
dos de cet animal et puis du coup ça
explique aussi sa visage donc sonné tout
écraser ses oreilles pointues ben ça
c'est des choses qu'on retrouve
classiquement chez les chauves-souris
taper chauve souris dans google et vous
verrez la tronche que ça une chauve
souris c'est assez effrayant cas
suivants donc ici qu'est ce qu'on a et
bien on a un squelette qui si les gens
qui croient que ceci est réellement un
squelette
enfin ces gens doivent réellement aller
se faire soigner je suis désolé je peux
rien faire pour vous si vous croyez
qu'un squelette peut ressembler à ça il
est réellement un problème médical
certainement un problème d'addiction
addiction aux boules shit sur internet
addiction à la drogue mais n'ont jamais
de la vie un squelette ça ressemble à ça
jamais donc ici on est face à un
assemblage extrêmement mal habile dos
complètement random j'attire votre
attention sur la colonne vertébrale qui
n'est même pas
fait deux vertèbres et je vais surtout
attirer votre attention sur le crâne
puisque comme nous en étions en
chauve-souris et bien on reconnaît une
fois de plus la fin globuleuses le prog
native et l'aurait interne très grande
très modifiée de chauves-souris donc la
tête est effectivement une véritable
tête mais c'est une tête de chauve
souris et le reste du squelette cdo
je vais même pas si c'est des os et des
trucs c'est un assemblage complètement
aléatoire de n'importe quoi kolélas les
uns aux autres pour ressembler vaguement
à un squelette
j'ai pas grand chose de plus à dire sur
un cas comme ça de même que pour le cas
suivant donc le cas suivant à gauche
vous avez soit disant un extraterrestre
donc encore une fois un squelette
complètement on importe quoi donc à
gauche vous auriez à un extraterrestre
avec des oeufs dans le ventre et à
droite et ben vous compare ce que ça
donne un vrai animal ici un caméléon
avec des vrais jeux dans le ventre donc
vous voyez que les oeufs sont en
surbrillance
oui mais ils sont pas complètement
opaque 1,9 c'est globalement creux il ya
quelque chose à l'intérieur là sur la
gauche on n'est pas face à d e on est
face à des cailloux donc c'est non ce ne
sont pas des oeufs ce sont juste des
cailloux qui ont été placées là et l'a
donc là pour le coup au moins la colonne
vertébrale on peut voir derrière est une
vraie colonne vertébrale mais on voit
surtout que les côtes ont été découpés
n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que ce
spécimen est un faux donc voilà juste
des cailloux cas suivants et là on
touche vraiment le fond mais vraiment le
fond du fond est-ce que ça ça ressemble
à des eaux pour vous non non jamais de
la vie n'ont jamais de la vie ça ce sont
des hausses assez des bouts de bâton ça
merci d'avoir essayé mais non ça me
convaincrez pas avec des choses comme ça
et ça se dit ce qu'on essaye de faire
passer pour un coût en réalité c'est une
phalange je sais pas qui ils l'ont piqué
je sais pas à quoi ils l'ont piqué mais
il n'y a aucun doute sur le fait que ça
c'est une phalange donc non on efface
encore une fois un assemblage malhabile
de tout et n'importe quoi et alors là
ils ne se donnent même pas la peine
d'utiliser d'utiliser des vrais aulas et
utilise des allumettes quoi donc je suis
désolé mais ma réaction c'est lol encore
un autre spécimen avec alors un crâne
qui est tellement sûre brillant que de
toute façon je peux pas vous dire ce que
c'est c'est certainement une pierre et
encore une fois des choses qu'on essaie
de le faire
passer pour des ovaires qui sont aussi
certainement des cailloux mais surtout
j'attire votre attention sur les côtes
cette chose n'a que trois paires de
côtes pourquoi pas est la colonne
vertébrale de cette chose ceci n'est pas
une colonne vertébrale dans aucune
dimension de l'existence il n'existe de
colonne vertébrale qui est cette tronche
là ce n'est pas une colonne vertébrale
ça c'est juste deux eaux qui ont été
cassés et mis l'un à côté de l'autre
enfin ça ça ne ressemble même pas à
squelette et encore une fois je le dis
si vous pensez que des choses comme ça
sont de véritables squelette faut
vraiment vous faire soigner
l'éducation ne peut plus rien pour vous
le système éducatif français ne peut
plus rien pour vous je suis désolé
attaquons maintenant les aliens de
sibérie là on a fait un peu le tour de
tout ce qui était en amérique du sud
maintenant la sibérie ceci est il un
alien
non quand on compare à un crâne de de
renard et bien cela saute aux yeux qu'il
ne s'agit absolument pas d'un
extraterrestre mais bel et bien d'un
petit renard de chez nous après je sais
pas quelle espèce non voilà ça c'est un
truc relativement proche du renard ya
des petites différences je dis pas il ya
des petites différences mais globalement
c'est un canidé c'est un canidé qui a
été pris dans la glace
et puis encore un qui a été découvert en
sibérie est qui et qui a vraiment une
sale tronche là pour le coup il a
vraiment une sale tronche et je dois
avouer que je n'ai aucune idée de ce
dont il pourrait s'agir par contre ce
dont je suis sûr c'est que ça ça
ressemble beaucoup à la texture d'une
peau de poulet bale bruce os de poulet
donc je sais pas ce que c'est mais ce
qui est certain c'est que les
extraterrestres ne semble pas dans de la
peau de tout l'est pour se tenir chaud
donc a priori je dirais que cette info
voilà cette vidéo se termine et que
conclure de tout ça est bien c'est que
soit il n'y a aucun extraterrestre dans
le lot soit tous ces extraterrestres
ressemble vachement à des trucs pour
trouve sur terre et je vous invite à
revoir la vidéo et a essayé de comparer
un peu la diversité morphologique de ces
extraterrestres
juste pour que vous constatiez à quel
point si les extraterrestres existent
en tout cas ils nous ont envoyé un gros
paquet de leur biodiversité dans l'âtre
et pour terminer cette conclusion et
bien je soulignerai sutout
la puissance de l'anatomie comparée qui
vous permet d'identifier de vrais faux
extraterrestre sans avoir à attendre que
les gens vous demandent du pognon pour
faire des analyses génétiques ou bien
pour aller se dorer la pilule au soleil
l'anatomie comparée suffit largement à
démêler le vrai du faux dans toutes ces
situations
donc la prochaine fois qu'on vous
demande de la thune soi disant pour
faire des analyses génétiques sur des
spécimens qui serait révolutionnaire
pour l'exobiologie prenez le temps de
comparer les spécimens en question avec
des choses qui existent sur terre et
seulement après vous réfléchissez à
savoir si ça vaut vraiment le coup sûr
une analyse génétique parce que là dans
tout ce que je vous ai montré il n'y a
pas besoin tout est largement
identifiable juste qu'on me compare
merci à tous et à très bientôt